I absolutely love this clip that I'm
going to play for you next here I'm
going to play for you video of a 23 year
old absolutely crushing a Fox News
so-called reporter so hard that you can
visibly see the Fox host unsure what to
do or how to react he is reduced to
sputtering and repeating the same things
over and over again this happened a few
days ago but someone just sent it to me
yesterday we've seen this type of thing
happened before one time I recall is
when right-wingers steven crowder did a
stunt where he goes to college campuses
and encourages random people to quote
change his mind
and this left-leaning sort of socialist
type sat down and just destroyed Crowder
and Crowder didn't know what what hidden
hit hit him he looked punch-drunk almost
this is very similar okay the topic here
is the green New Deal Fox News sent this
mush brained reporter Todd Pierrot to
ask people how are we gonna pay for the
green New Deal and he happened to sit
down and talk to 23 year old Jack vandal
of in a diner in Missouri and vandala
started rattling off correct precise and
pithy rapid-fire responses and Pierrot
was visibly shaken from it able only to
repeat his same questions over and over
again time and time again and repeat
Vanda loves answers back to him let's
take a look at this just beautiful
backfire of the Fox News on the street
sort of narrative crafting interview
that they like to do jack is an info
specialist and he really wants Howard
Schultz to talk about climate change
specifically the green new deal which
you support why do you support it yeah
it's really important we keep below two
degrees Celsius of average warming
otherwise the consequences are gonna be
devastating how do we pay for yeah how
did we pay for World War two at the end
of the day when something is this
important our economy is gonna suffer if
we don't pay for it okay but you do
agree with the sentiment that this is as
big a deal climate change that is as
World War two yeah I mean for a little
over 40,000 Americans died in World War
two and climate change is killing a
hundred fifty thousand people per year
at least let's talk about the money
because that's a huge part of this how
are we going to pay for yeah so during
World War two
for one thing the government just pushed
some of the cash upfront and raised some
tax
on some folks but at the end of the day
it's stimulated the economy so much that
everyone benefited okay so to review you
are in favor of raising taxes in order
to support the green you do if that's
the optimal solution economists sort out
I'll go with that
Oh quick get me some guy in a maggot at
to talk about bringing back coal or
something like that this guy is off
script truly well done by twenty
three-year-old Jack Van de la vie
completely commend him here and the
funniest part about this is that the
answer is he gives a really really
simple we've got to take care of the
planet and stop ruining it and the
question of money is never a question
when it's about Wars or weapons we have
money it's just a question of priorities
and Todd Perot is sort of out of his
league here he has nothing prepared
he can't even fall back on some weak and
flaccid oh but what about inflation sort
of thing and he just repeats so you're
okay raising taxes to pay for it and of
course at that point Vanda loves got him
in his hand and this is not about the
specific provisions of the green New
Deal or whether it's all doable in eight
ten or twelve years this is a bigger
issue and the issue is the discussion
about how to pay for it is a misleading
discussion and it's a hypocritical
discussion it's misleading because
number one it doesn't deal in reality
with how government spending works and
number two it ignores the negative
externalities of not dealing with our
dirty energy usage and then it's
hypocritical because the right only asks
about how to pay for it when it's
something that they don't want when it's
wars or missiles or tax cuts for the
rich we just do it the same way that we
could do it with the green new deal and
when young people call in to the show
and ask me hey David how do I better
engage in arguments and debates with
people who disagree with me I talked
about well you've got to be prepared
it's good to understand the other side's
views as well as you do your own the
explanations don't have to be
complicated but they have to be real and
they have to work in this case Vanda
love was prepared todd Piro
was definitely not prepared and really
importantly then
was not only prepared with the what but
with the how to say it he knew that in
this format you need quick snappy pithy
and concise statements and he had him
ready and lots of people have the
knowledge that Vanda love has they know
the facts they know the truth about the
green New Deal but when a fox reporter
shoves a mic in your face and gives you
50 seconds you aren't always ready to
express it so clearly and concisely the
way vandal of did on both counts
substance and delivery Jack Vandal of
crushed it and I congratulate him and
just absolutely a pleasure to watch